hello everybody welcome to part 19 of
let's play penumbra overture ah as you
know we got some chemicals dodged a worm
all pro like oh yeah this looks like a
worm cavern I'm definitely not gonna die
multiple times let's do it Oh
oh yeah oh yeah yeah painkillers
oh yeah ten 1000 I don't care Joe
Freeman ah I know that guy
brother Gordon John oh hey John oh he's
talking to me
John Oh huh yep
John Oh wasn't so good uh-huh
John Oh John Oh John Oh uh-huh yeah Oh
cool story bro oh oh it's cool I like
this
Oh yep uh-huh what why do you keep
touching them cuz I'm making I'm
controlling your every move
alright looks like we got some ice here
I'm probably not fall through and die oh
that's yep that happened oh boy
yep yep yep dead dead of course I knew
it was gonna happen so why did I do it
who knows
alright just testing it late all the
skills are made ah come on
huh let's start a counting how many
times I die if you get the right number
at the end of the video uh I'll write
you a personalized message how about
that
ah not again
why does that kill instantly oh oh hey
uh huh Oh got you
oh so smart Oh brain just out of control
all right this looks good
uh-huh Oh won't catch me up watch this
yeah okay am I missing something do I
need like to make a raft at up something
or whatnot um uh oh I get it
oh I get it I get it I think I get it if
not I'm just gonna keep dying welp this
is entertaining for you ah ah come on
all right again I'm nothing if not
persistent I see the line the brake line
ah ah yeah Oh so badass oh so bad news
all right let me break this section ha
ha or not today I'll give me that wood
that was not a euphemism all right leap
skills Inc are you are solely oh great
oh so great where's another ah I see it
I see it
Oh Oh all cracked out here there's
another one
oh yeah what do I even need to go I
don't know surprise somewhere over there
Oh another brake line Oh gonna bring it
bring it
Oh what's these beats killed oh oh so
great oh man ya'll must be so
entertained uh-huh yeah whatever they're
even a brake line I don't see a brake
line going slowly oh oh yeah up on the
hill here oh nothing ah nothing oh let
me live let me live let me live up no
let me die alright crack don't talk back
alright I didn't need to go that way so
obviously I need to go oh what's that I
see you lose some
it's your monster lol monster oh I think
I know what it is my guess it looks like
a hand holding something out of the
frozen one that's that's got creepy
alright come on where's that bring my
hello the brake ah there it is gotcha
ah yeah oh yeah all right Oh
Oh so lee.toma oh it's gonna be so
awesome
Oh jump jump ollie Oh skills Oh Oh
double ah there's no part other parts of
the hand Oh
crowbar Joe Freeman ha ha I get it as a
crowbar come on gore-tex glove uh-huh
yeah um oh boy
come in hey clip now shut up that would
be that would work
that would work dump some chemicals on
it shut up shut up
nope nope maybe because they're all
chemicals oh yeah this will work
yep ha ha
Oh crowbar oh yeah this game actually
does have a couple references version
Freeman I mean they're there they're not
solid connections but they're there all
right Oh get ready for this Oh so great
I'll look at me oh yeah oh yeah I know
No aah Oh still great still great Oh on
again oh yeah
Oh who's the best Oh me is there
anything over there I don't know go
check about awesome ice jumping skills
oh oh not like it ain't no thang Oh
crack
what's here nothing nothing at all
why are they coming no reason what a
fish how does a fish survive in there
this game makes no sense all right let
me guess a worm pop up out of nowhere I
bet I just bet bring it on I'm ready for
you
Oh No yeah I thought you were too scared
yep victory flash oh yeah all right what
do I got in my note
ah disorders a sinner a - right - all
got the tool oh yeah oh so smart
doggy I'll go around that's what an
intelligent person would do oh you know
on a tangle with May I'm untangle a ball
oh oh
close the door on your face oh using all
this amnesia stick I close the door
yeah amnesia skills oh right where am i
where am i okay incinerate oh yeah Oh
instant memory got in my brain yep I
don't even need to look at you Matt I
know where I'm going yep oh yeah are you
impressed
are you entertained yet oh just like
that snap one hand didn't even eat a try
okay where am I
Oh fan it's either Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory or half-life again I
don't know
oh we got Oh lemme guess
worm uh-huh yeah whatever
yeah I have an explosives book when did
I pick up an explosives book explosive
book okay all right yeah okay did that
um I don't know
yeah tanti red phosphorus barium don't
have that probably this I don't know I
don't know I got chemicals what up this
looks stable but I'm just going for it
oh yeah lightning quick Oh parkour
parkour oh yeah
parkour yeah I'm the best get out of
here I'll open up why would you open
inside that's just stupid dangerous I'm
air get me our contents but you got
nothing
what do you even exist uh-huh the
explosives book being my guide Oh spring
Oh fuse oh I get a premade fuse here oh
so dumb what we got more whispers
maybe I shouldn't touch those things
uh-huh what what is a game gonna change
if I never touch those things in the
beginning Oh
oh now you're making up for all the
painkillers that you didn't have good
thing I would have punched you in the
face if you didn't oh right
oh yeah here uh-huh for my glass beaker
up here turn on this light it with my
lighter lighter oh so smart and just
start dropping chemical then that'll
work oh no not en a process of
elimination nope
it's 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
possible permutations of this so I'll go
through them all get ready to be
entertained I know it's in my book I
know I know you're screaming at me like
it's in my book I'm not gonna look at my
book I'm just gonna draw all dog humor
tape permutations nope nope ok nevermind
I'm I'm obviously doing this wrong nope
nope oh yeah I learned a note I press n
to do that oh okay
explosive book big book of explosives
let's see
ha ba ba ba nitroglycerin sodium
bicarbonate and yep yep okay
all right uh-huh
death mix red phosphorus and barium all
right I don't actually I don't know I
don't know actually what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna pause it here figure it out so
you don't have to watch me be an idiot
that's entertaining as that is yeah I
won't subject you to it
okay thank you so much for watching and
I will see you in part 20 of let's play
penumbra overture bye bye